هذه الحشود بالطبع عرضة
للهجوم
مدى حقيقة هذا التهديد الذي يمثله تنظيم
الدولة ، والتهديد حقيقي ، وهو حاد
ومستمر ، وهو شيء
نركز عليه مع كل أداة في
ترسانتنا يتمتع قادتنا على
الأرض بمجموعة متنوعة من القدرات
أنهم يستخدمونه للدفاع عن المطار
ضد هجوم إرهابي محتمل ،
ونحن نعمل بجد مع
مجتمع استخباراتنا لمحاولة عزل
وتحديد المكان الذي قد يأتي
منه الهجوم ، وهو أمر
نوليه أولوية قصوى لإيقافه أو
تعطيله وسنفعله  كل
ما في وسعنا ما دمنا على
الأرض أه لمنع حدوث ذلك
ولكننا نأخذ الأمر على
محمل الجد.
وتشارك القاعدة أيضًا
في المفاوضات والأمن في
كابول ، وصُنف زعيمها
كإرهابي قبل عقد من الزمان
.  بالتنسيق مع
شبكة حقاني التي
نتعامل معها عبر القنوات العسكرية
مع طالبان ، من الواضح
إلى حد كبير أو مندمج
مع شبكة حقاني ،
جهدنا مع قادة طالبان
العسكريين المسؤولين حاليًا عن
الأمن في كابول لأنهم بحاجة إلى
فهم
ذلك  يحتاج الأمريكيون وأولئك الذين عملوا
معنا إلى ممر آمن إلى المطار
، وإذا تعطل هذا الممر أو تعطلت
العمليات مع
الولايات المتحدة ، فسوف تقدم استجابة سريعة وقوية